my sound is weird oh is that because
try clapping
i can only hear it in my left ear maybe
it's your ears that are can you turn my
right ear on do you still have your ear
wax in have you been swimming
remember the kids that would have to
like plug up their ears with wax to go
swimming they'd like no they didn't
maybe earplugs yeah i had to do you yeah
you can only hear glenn you said
i can only hear in my out of your right
way hold on a second plugged in all the
way down there oh look at that no yeah
okay that was it wow sometimes it's as
simple as that sometimes
guys i had a um our fireplace was not
working we have a gas fireplace in the
in the family room and uh we had a
technician come out and check it out
and uh
and it you know he was there for about
15 minutes before he like basically just
realized like all i had to do was change
the batteries
in like a thing that like whatever the
control is that controls the
thing it was just like he just took the
batteries out and put new batteries in
and i was like yeah well that's just
embarrassing but also really frustrating
that like my you know when we had the
house built like nobody told me nobody i
didn't know it had batteries well
imagine going back only i don't know 30
40 years to a different generation and
explain to them that you need batteries
to control your fire well by the way i
hate it i i want you can't in california
you can't have real fireplaces anymore
it's against code i would love to have a
real fireplace yeah much better i had a
situation like that one is a little off
topic but i was at a bar in rhode island
it was winter time i this was when i
still living in new york so i hadn't
driven a car in a while and i had my
parents car and i i was meeting up with
tim roach our editor and some of my
rhode island buddies and uh i think we
were like watching a patriots game and
it was snowing it was really snowing i
was like all right guys i gotta head out
and i get in my car
and i'm trying to drive the car and i
just can't get it to go i can't get it
to like
i'm like
the tires are spinning in the snow and
i'm like okay i'm a little out of
practice i haven't driven a car in a few
years
and
i'm like i can't get it my buddy comes
out he's like trying to give it a little
push
and a cop a couple that comes sees us
and he comes over to help and i'm like
oh man okay i have i had too much to
drink but i was all right i was like not
endorsing drinking and driving maybe i
like a beer too but
enough to be nervous about it so then
the cop the cops looking at me and
spitting like wheels are spinning i was
trying to figure out he looks in the
window and goes buddy
is the emergency breakup
i did not realize that the emergency
brake
was up i was like yeah i think
i put it down and i think because my
buddy who owned the bar was like a
like a real local guy uh you know the
cop was like go home get home so i got
high let you honey let you drive home go
home
yeah
yeah well i don't know our credits are
sincere you know sometimes sometimes
they are i have a very similar story
actually uh
me and my bunch of my buddies were on
acid and we needed to move my friend's
car
and uh and and he couldn't find his keys
so we're like well we'll just push it
you know what i mean like we'll put it
in neutral and push it and we couldn't
figure out how to push it it wouldn't go
we were like what the hell's going on it
was in a driveway it was on a on a uh
it should have very easily gone and it
was the exact same thing we emerged we
had the emergency break up and but we
were all too
well sometimes sometimes sometimes
yeah i think what we've learned is
sometimes the the fireplace needs new
batteries sometimes you're on you're
drunk or on lsd and your emergency break
is on and sometimes you find out you
have a new dad
[Music]
charlie is this the first time we
established that you don't know who your
dad is
that we actually talk about it i can't
remember
a lot of dad things is this the first
time we meet max dad this is the first
time we meet max dad yeah yes yeah
gregory scott gregory scott cummins oh
my god what a what a treasure i mean you
know what i remember when we cast him
we watched a vhs tape of his like reel
that's how long we've been doing the
show the casting sent over although dvd
technology existed but casting had sent
over a vhs tape all casting was being
sent to us uh via vhs tape at that point
in time so i mean we we auditioned a ton
of actors little known yeah somebody
came in and read for us who went on to
become a rather big star
who read for that
read for that role huh
read for the dad
right for the day your dad yeah and i
think he got down to i mean there were
so many great actors that came in
because it was a i think was a really
funny part and they knew and people got
it and they and i remember him doing a
pretty good job i remember there was
like three or four guys that we really
liked yeah and i remember we had called
them back my god who was it dave
bautista
get
no no dave batista yeah how was he 10
years older than us agent casting is a
thing man 52. he's 52 yeah he went too
young so he's he
that's a bit young and by the way
gregory scott commons we had to age him
up too um i i can't remember how old he
is but
i know no i haven't seen it yet she's
bautista in that
plays uh the villain and yeah he's very
good actor but like
yes he's a very good actor okay get the
[ __ ] out of here um
anyway he's definitely like glenn
mouthing it to me like
cameras
i'm an actor i know where the cameras
are um
anyways he plays he plays uh
himself yeah but there's a scene where
he plays himself just yeah with makeup
on he plays himself with makeup on yeah
and
you're ruthless man ruthless no he came
in here this is your oscar i'm sorry
where's your oscar you want to go down
in the car and get your oscars you
remember me yeah i'm good you're shag
away listen there were people's choice
award there was a whole thing there
won't be any awards in there but it will
be it will be parked perfectly
that's right yeah
you want a parking award
i'm gonna get that one off the record i
just i i i don't understand why people i
don't think he's acting
i think the guy looks like to me he
looks like he doesn't he's like
shocked that he's
he looks like he's constantly on the
verge of like
like i'm gonna be discovered like people
are gonna figure out that i'm not really
an actor
i'm just
yeah
yeah let's cut that we're going to cut
all that
because uh
the guy does not deserve that i have not
seen him give a good performance but i'd
like to and i'm going to watch that
movie so maybe he'll be great i haven't
seen
yeah yes what are you talking about so
what are you talking about
but uh you can't put this out guys but i
i kind of agree with you man i'm not uh
sure can we put it in megan but can we
beep can we beep it
and then put and then put literally like
bat like bubbles over the mouth so you
don't know who
we're talking about or what movies we're
we're talking about there's maybe a way
to cut that sure i mean sorry use that
edit that into the show yeah okay well
whatever maybe don't cut that maybe
don't cut that what what were we talking
about so we made a television show okay
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and now
we're at the end of the second season of
it
yeah right and the episode's called
dennis and dee get a new dad i really
liked so much of this one i
liked just how sort of
you know i love the scene with you guys
and your mom in the restaurant where
danny finds out that uh he's not the dad
just the dynamic between you guys and
and archer yeah
and danny is fantastic every time i
watch an episode with ann in it i'm like
man what a great character why did why
did we what happened i don't know i mean
it was a good it was a good idea it was
a good storyline it was an interesting
storyline but
i think we really shot ourselves in the
foot by killing that character because
she was so great we're not projecting
that far into the future so we're just
like oh my god what are we going to do
this is a fun story let's kill a
character we don't realize the
repercussions that
we're going to say
i think
the show as much as we try to not change
it so much it has to change it has to
move forward because i watch every
episode being like god damn it i love
that why aren't we doing that and it's
because you can't just do that you can't
just repeat the same thing over and over
and over again so you know yes we could
have hung onto an archer for longer but
we didn't we only had it for one season
we only had yeah one season yeah these
foolish young kids who thought i mean i
thought probably the show would go maybe
four years tops so yeah maybe that's
what we were thinking i don't know but
well charlie wasn't thinking at all when
he and neither none of us were when we
wrote in oh bad news the bad new tattoo
that you were gonna have to wear that
for the next 12 15 years of your life
you know there was a decision where we
could have
been like nah whatever it was a fake
tattoo because we cut the whole riff
about it there was a riff where you say
what are you trying to do
oh right and i'm like i'm trying to get
hard
and you're like what are you writing and
i'm like writing bad news and you're
like yeah but that's two words i also
stopped because it's hurting me too much
and we cut that you know like just
because the episode was too long yeah
and we cut the whole riff yeah and yet
kept the tattoo and yet kept the tattoo
it's a fantastic tattoo it's a good
tattoo i thought about getting it in
real life many times i should name it
you should always have a little last
minute decision of like
[ __ ] it i like the idea that um
maybe this is it feels like the first
time where we have a major character who
shows the
complete opposite of the characters that
that are the main cast of the show right
like a reflection
of like who these characters could have
been if they had good parents
i also like that we're showing
who the how these people became who they
became yeah like slowly but surely well
they're very they're all still real
people they're they're very
bad and arched but there are still real
people and compared to their new father
that they find out is
just the complete opposite of yeah a
little thing though a little thing that
i caught that i loved i remember
doing it was um that we put in uh claire
de lune the piano there in the um
uh in the gugino's yeah and it cuts out
like as danny's having his rent yes and
then it starts back in again just as if
there's a piano player somewhere no no
no which we later established there as a
piano player
yes we did in the episode where you give
the speech about uh tasting someone's
[ __ ] or something like that yeah
right tastings
just a little bit it wasn't great but it
was fine but it was fine um
it actually cuts out um uh when i scream
i'm not banging my sister yeah yeah yeah
but i i always thought that was a really
really fun fun choice also to have that
cut out and then there's just a pause
and then it comes back in also the
gunshots versus clicks when danny is
ranting and raving i wanted to talk
about that yeah well let's get into that
let's get into that so that was another
instance where we got into an argument
in the editing room i believe both you
guys wanted to put the gunshots in how
do you feel about it now 15. i think
it's
[ __ ] ridiculous
i absolutely 100
think that that is one of the dumbest
things we have ever oh god got to that's
so hard i was like that's so good why
don't we do showing that anymore i think
that was one that was definitely an
example of where
at first i remember being like i don't i
think this is so dumb and then charlie
winning me over and being like let me
just try it i'm like i don't think it's
gonna work
we left or whatever he put them all in
and i came in i was like okay he wins
that was so great and you were still in
the uh first of all it's not funny
secondly it's completely first you're
wrong it is funny
it's hilarious no it isn't not so much
the gun firing but then the dry firing
after he's fired all the guns and it's
just clicking away it's great it's not
it's not it is it doesn't make a
decrease
in a in a giant building and there's no
no there's no like debris falling from
the ceiling it's just completely we
didn't have a free budget at that time
right but right right which is why we
shouldn't have put it in it it's it's
just so like so wacky and broad and we
did
because on the day
that's danny was supposed to or frank
was just supposed to be clicking he
wasn't even clicking he was just
gesturing with it oh that's even funnier
so he was not even yeah yeah
we were putting the little clicks and
fires and you guys listen it's so stupid
but it's i can't it but it's funny
it's damn funny
maybe we should do a lot of things
can we do like a listener do we have the
technology to do that we can do that
listener paul okay is it was that well
how do we pose the question was the
scene funny no not was the scene funny
the scene's funny sure is danny firing
the gun funny do you enjoy it or does it
ruin the scene for you
uh thumbs up if you like it i i thumbs
down if you don't i'm going to guess
that
most people were like yeah i know it's
funny yeah i mean because most people
know it's funny you're the person who
thinks nothing's funny you don't think
rob's parking's funny
you don't think no that was funny
it just made me angry but it was funny
well what you said was which i love you
recognized that it was funny but it
didn't make your mind it didn't make me
laugh i understand that's correct i
understand that yeah yeah no but i but i
acknowledge that it's funny the him
firing the gun thing is not is not funny
to me and it annoyed me this time
watching it too i was like
this is the dumb one of the dumbest
choices we've ever made like
and we've done it a number of times
again and then
and every time frank pulls that gun out
we do discuss like oh wait and charlie's
always the one who's like we should put
a gunshot in and then wow like um
sometimes
we do it and sometimes we don't yeah
it's funny he's so goddamn reckless with
this to me
here's what i think would have been
funny if he was
gesturing with it and you guys were like
yeah reacting reacting as if like a
man's waving a gun around which is what
would happen in real life
uh
and then
and then at the very end he like shot
one into the scene like and everybody
agreed that would have been funnier but
that ship had sailed and there was still
a way to make the scene just a little
bit funnier than it was
so you admit it's just a little bit
funny yeah but that's what we're going
for a little bit funnier versus
versus reality yeah no i'm not trying to
make reality
whatever let's move past it i uh this is
what i thought this is what it is still
to this day actually in the writers room
this is the process this is the process
it's the process i love these guys i
really do yeah i love that we can do
this it is insane that this is a
profession it's insane what do we do is
an argument over whether or not you put
a gun sound effect in
and to have a passion and argue about it
yes yes like crazy
man you know like i got really upset
about that
you know what i mean like you have to
like take a breath and be like [ __ ] man
like i felt real anger over that is the
dumbest [ __ ] ever well that's true it's
so great right this crazy thing about
this right is we're you are trying to
find some kind of truth right you're
trying to find some kind of truth this
scene feels real the moment feels real
for the characters
and that joke pushed it out of the truth
for you which is why you don't like it
right that's that little
sort of uh ticker you have in your gut
that says this works this doesn't work
takes me out of it right for me
sometimes i'm like well there's the
there's the realistic truth there's the
comedic truth you know like when you
pitch that sweet that you would see
sweet dee as an ostrich
you know
and i was like well that's crazy i mean
like wait you actually think she's an
ostrich when you see her and then you
know we were like well let's shoot one
then i got the other you know i'm like
that [ __ ] works great i would by the
way i was 100 on board for that right
right away i was like that is
brilliant yeah and i didn't see it i
didn't see that we could go that far i
was like to me it seems the outside of
the yeah i could see a man firing a gun
in his apartment i can't see a man
actually hallucinating an actual bird
yeah until i s until he saw in the
editing room there was like nah it works
perfectly it works great right yeah so
and that was wasn't that that was a so
actually well i mean i guess we'll tell
that story when we get to it um but uh i
mean i remember we were doing a photo
shoot and that bird was there for the
photo shoot and that was the same day i
believe or something that we were filter
magazine and i want to say that was the
only magazine we've ever been on the
cover cover of
oh yeah we got a lot of offers now still
to be we get we do get offers now
to be to be on covers of certain
magazines that we do that we pass on
because
because we don't want to we don't i
personally use to me this is news to me
yeah i'm not aware of these offers we've
got yeah we've gotten we've gotten a few
a handful over there but but now we're
at a place where like well now see we
needed you at a certain point like there
was a run in the show for the first i
don't know eight nine years where we
really needed the the promotion and and
the publicity and they were not there
for us and then all of a sudden now
we are now promotion for them right and
like so i i how how does that seem fair
where now we're going to help promote
your magazine when yeah when we needed
you and the poor copy editor is like i
was 10 when this song right right right
and i don't know what right well you're
blaming me i'm sorry i'm not aware of
all that i'm not aware of coming
i don't even care if he's in the photos
if he doesn't want if he wants to pass
on it that's fine
you know i mean
maybe we would be if i wasn't putting
gunshots in danny's con right they'd be
like they'd be like no now we yeah yeah
they're like these [ __ ] guys aren't
taking this [ __ ] seriously they're not
taking it seriously
oh man
yeah
can we can one thing
that i i i found like i found really
funny uh about the show that was the
first time and i already brought this up
a little bit but the idea that we're
seeing for the first time
how important parents are
like parenting is and how like
the question of like nature versus
nurture is coming up we're like well how
do these people how are these people
existing like what led them to this
place and we weren't doing it on purpose
and we were just like desperate for
storylines but the idea of starting to
see backstory and to start to see it and
understand how these characters got to
them no we were absolutely well i mean i
mean to
to what extent i'm not sure but but i
mean
in
in my memory we were we were doing that
on purpose we were very deliberately
you know showing
what could have been
you know had they been raised by bruce
mathis versus being raised by frank
reynolds
um and uh
it's it's it's really fun to watch that
that
those interactions with them like really
trying to kind of fit in with him at
first and then they go to the hospital
they just can't help themselves yeah
she's stealing medication we can't help
but blab about which kids are going to
be probably die and should we say
something or not and
and then all of a sudden we're like hey
yeah we're too far gone and we can't
even we're like
these kids are dying and work we're like
it's
complaining about hospital food and the
fact that it's too cold
in this room and can we crank the heat
up like um
yeah
yeah but in the end what's what's great
is that if you're watching the show at
that point it's because you get what
we're doing and you're enjoying the
characters so that when you
and d realize that like oh you know who
never made us feel bad about like these
kinds of conversations dad you're
actually happy for them because you're
like oh that brings them back to the
characters that we love right
and we love them for how repulsive they
are yeah because we understand what what
the show is
you know
but that's an interesting phenomenon
that you're rooting for them you're not
rooting for the good guy in the story
yeah right like if do you remember the
the whole thing with breaking bad
and how like there was this huge
backlash against
um
skyler
oh yeah yeah right yeah the starting
character of skylar they people were
disliking her like yes yeah she was the
remember the sh the show so she was the
the
the mother and wife yeah in the show and
she was essentially the moral compass
for like a while right and
and people like actively hated her to
the point where the actor was getting
yeah was getting like publicly um yeah
like getting [ __ ] from people and it
was because
the audience was like oh no we know that
walter is like a sociopath who's turning
into a psychopath or whatever and we're
on board for that that's the show that's
the promise of the show so anybody who's
like a good guy who's taking us away
from who that character is is like
pushing us further away from the promise
of the show right i don't know i think
that's an interesting phenomenon yeah
well is it just as simple as you know
you're telling a story you have a
character protagonist right they have a
want they have a driving wants whether
they're
that's a good want or a bad want they
have a want there's something relatable
in that to everyone and then the person
who is obstructing them
uh is annoying to the audience just the
way that a person obstructing you from
your want is annoying is it is it maybe
just that yeah well i also think there's
something interesting about empathy
that's not necessarily like intellectual
like if we explain empathy to glenn
[Laughter]
to sort of break it down like
like what the feelings are and let's
that's a feeling
yes
[Music]
how about the idea that we're talking
about myspace yeah oh yeah yeah yeah my
space yeah there's definitely
right now a section of our a demographic
of our audience that doesn't know what
mice it's never heard of myself right i
gotta say i've sort of felt the same way
like watching the thing i'm like wait
what was my space oh yeah right yeah
were you out i know you were on myspace
i was like i was on it you were on it
okay i couldn't remember i wasn't on
friendster
no but i was on my space yeah and then i
wha i've never had a facebook account
yeah but do you remember that this was
an era of the in internet intranet where
uh char someone had set up a fan account
and it was called charlieday.net
um do you guys remember charlieday.net
yeah yeah
yes
a nice young lady who i think was like
maybe from chicago or something and she
well here is the funny thing she was a
big fan of third watch oh
right she was a big third watch fan and
then tried to get into sunny as sunny
happened and then i think eventually i
must have gotten tired of me over the
course of signing being like this isn't
the this isn't the sexy uh
drug dealer guy boy bad boy that i
thought he was this is a man who's
eating cat food
and huffing elmer's glue uh this is not
the guy for me so eventually
[Laughter]
but that was i mean that was really our
experience with the internet and the
closest thing we had to social media
which was the only way we could tell how
people felt about the show
was going to imdb
remember and then you
there were you they were that would be
like the message board do they still
have a message board on imdb they must
have dreams they must but do you
remember that we started they dropped it
right yeah oh they did yeah because
because they're talking about the worst
so but that was like the first version
of a message board that we had and then
we started do you remember we started we
started messaging each other so i've
started one that was like hey glenn
howard is a [ __ ] dick right i hate
his face yeah and then i put it out
there yeah and then we were basically
battling each other but
it was just like a gag to us and then
like hundreds of people started like
chimed in yeah and then we started and
then it became not funny anymore to
where you were like oh this is like
personal and then we stopped reading
them and then luckily we just didn't
have twitter just didn't exist so we
didn't have to read any anything about
us yeah yeah yeah
yeah i mean i was reading i mean i was
reading comments on myspace but by the
time i don't know i think i got off of
myspace like 2007 2008 i was like done
with it as was everyone else yeah yeah
what a thing man imagine being like the
tom
right wasn't it tom from myspace
and being like this is the it's taking
off this is going to be the thing tom
did great because he's they sold myspace
to like fox or something my friend this
is good crazy but they said they sold it
to
sold it to [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah
yeah and then fox was like
yeah like what was that like they could
it was huge they could i feel like they
could have really like rivaled facebook
with that
and they just kind of like too late they
might try to maybe they'll try to revive
it yeah revive it how much did old tom
make in that in that d how much did they
buy it for do you know we're gonna meg's
gonna look that up we i like that kind
of stuff
i want to know how much tom
made uh i wonder how much that was sold
for because
580 million dollars
in 2004 in 2005. facebook must have been
out there at the same time and he just
got it out
quicker because so i have i have become
very good friends with the person who
was the ceo and chairman of myspace was
he was and he was the one that sold it
to rupert murdoch okay at fox and he
told me the whole story and it's wild go
well basically he he was summoned to fox
summoned
because they were trying to figure out
like okay what's the next bring him to
me
that's rubber
email joke about [ __ ] [ __ ] my speech
i want to know who this guy is
bring him to me i don't want your jokes
[Laughter]
arnold cows [ __ ] space it is he still
my boss
no he sold he sold us
to the mouse okay who's my boss now
john disney john disney so keep your
traps shut
[ __ ] off rupert i'll smack you around
ruby
[ __ ] her off [ __ ] don't you [ __ ]
how dare you
all
right how dare you listen now y'all [ __ ]
i'm gonna buy this space whether you
like it or not
it's jump change mate
jump jump australia yes australia i
thought it was british
he's australian mate yeah yeah how are
you going how are you going there you're
going right
the scene in the hallway
when we're walking having uh between
charlie and i oh yeah we're walking with
uh with our new
costumes outfits yeah yeah that i i love
that scene and i love be because i love
when the i love writing acting in scenes
where the characters are
in agreement
that like what they're doing is awesome
but they're disagreeing about the
specifics
yeah right like both on the same page
and in conflict over the details yeah
whereas like the audience is maybe at
first led to believe like
what they're doing is ridiculous and
that they recognize that and that's not
what it is we recognize no we both we
look awesome it's just that you're
buttoning you're not doing it right
right
you're not doing it right and i remember
you had a very you were like i really
want to do it with the top button down
and i was like and i remember even when
we were talking about i was like i don't
know that that's the look and you were
like well that's what the scene should
be about and that's what we end up doing
all right yeah
yeah i i like you asking like is it is
it bunchy yeah it's a am i done like
bungee is it bunching or is it bunchy
that's funny um yeah no that that that
that seems great i like that look i mean
i think that's a good thing
yeah i wish i can't you know i can't get
away with it but like yeah i like it
it's good luck it's a cool look yeah
it's pretty sweet i also remember not
being nice silhouette you know like the
top button yeah flowy
yeah it's a nice silhouette
i go to those guys hey you guys whatever
you got going on here is great man you
got a great silhouette i really like it
you know what i mean i really like i
like this i'm sorry can you stand in
front of the light so i can see you in
shadow yes look at that celery look at
that
look at that look at that
i know how would a person respond to
that and what's going on with this car
no no no no no come on man
come on
yeah just giant stuff yeah yeah
okay but for me okay so my my favorite
scene in the whole episode i have to say
is the scene where you guys quickly walk
up to bruce mathis uh with the intention
of bashing him
and then you freak out and peel off
leaving charlie alone amazing with him
that whole sequence was so funny and i
wanted to ask you because i don't
totally remember
uh i feel like you kind of came up with
that whole repeating
what he's saying back to him very
tentatively like in the moment i don't
think that was in the script
i doesn't seem like a thing we would
have scripted no i feel like it was
something you and
and when stephen collins the actor
laughs and tells you it's okay
that was a brilliant moment because that
was him i think that was him breaking
but using it
like yeah i remember him kind of loud
he's like he's it's
it's okay
it's okay and he's kind of laughing yeah
i think because you guys were you were
breaking
during that because it was super funny
yeah and steven was breaking too because
it was super funny and steven was such a
great actor that he just used it
he just used it and and that whole scene
is so i feel like i remember addius
getting irritated about us he was
laughing he was or he's like let's go
keep it together yeah addie is our adius
who again directed all 10 episodes and
you know came from mostly drama i don't
know if he had really done any comedy at
that point
not much oh god i love that guy but he
was like you know he's like this is
we're taking this seriously you know
what i mean and uh
damn right totally right you know i
think it helped too which is like okay
good someone someone's getting irritated
let's get this yeah
what i really like about that is rob
your peel off is fantastic we are making
a beeline and you fire out of there i
kind of forgotten that you fired out of
there in that way of course you're
laughing as i'm smacking you
i'm laughing through the whole episode
absolutely i mean that scene you guys
are both i mean you're you're br almost
breaking into a full laugh at the end of
that slapping scene i i could see on the
corner of my face that i was like
smile and it's also so clear that he's
slapping me for real oh yeah that was
not fake like he wasn't smacking me that
was awesome
two scenes before that where
he's we're and where my dad is talking
about or we're where you were talking
about how
how full we were going to be for you how
full it was going to be and that wasn't
scripted and i just remember not being
able to get through that yeah well you
have to cut immediately after you stay
on the line yeah yeah that's that's all
that's bloopers that's all the bloopers
yeah also i gotta say just singing save
the children i found it so funny yeah
yeah save save save save save the
children
well here's what would you think that
was steven spanley yeah that was yeah
that was his band yeah yeah here's a fun
fact uh the girl that i'm hitting on in
that scene is an actress named yada
martinez and um
yada introduced me to my wife jill
which you guys know yes
people out there they may not know that
they probably don't why would they
anyway
yada martinez
thank you yeah thank you
thanks for the wife thanks for the wife
yatta
[Music]
do you guys have this i have a moment
every time i start one of these episodes
where i'm like oh my god am i really
gonna re-watch every single episode of
the show not that i don't like the show
but just the
the the undertaking just seems
exhausting to me just because we've
already put so much thought and effort
into these things that like to go back
and then by the time i'm done with the
episode i've i've
enjoyed going for that
ride and that trip down memory lane but
i find the task daunting every single
time i sit down to do it i just have a
moment just a flashing moment of it it's
it's strange because i bring it i
haven't been watching them with caitlin
which i should do
but i bring moments up in the episodes
because what happens is i forget them
completely and then as i'm watching them
they i remember them so well because we
spent so much time in the editing room
on them right so then all of a sudden it
like comes flashing back then i go and
exp and then i say hey remember that
moment i said to kaitlyn it was so funny
when you did this she has zero
recollection right because she was there
on the day and did it and then maybe
watched it once yeah i'm saying has she
ever seen the show we don't like that
every time i talk to her about it she's
like
what yeah
that's a different thing thanks like
like she doesn't remember [ __ ] there was
like a few years where she where we
didn't watch i was so sick of it by the
time it aired that i don't know that we
went i don't think i would remember
anything if we didn't spend all the time
in the editing room have there been
entire episodes that she has not seen
yeah probably
wow i know and i used to get really
upset by that
or or if she would be like if we would
watch maybe we stopped at a certain
point because we would watch them and
then she would like get up and like go
and do something with the cat or the dog
or the dish you know what i mean and i'm
like and of course this is the way
people watch tv so you can't have
judgment on it but i'd be like
we put so much work into this and you're
just getting up and just doing whatever
it's like you know what i don't want to
watch it with you
yeah you're in the show sure you're in
the show and you won't sit down
yeah yeah by the way i i'm not sure you
know jill says she thinks this show is
funny but i watch it with her and she's
not laughing
most of the time like every once in a
while like this this season season 15
i don't think i heard her laugh once
except for when we got to
the episode that you and i were talking
about on the vulture podcast the other
day
uh where you know i'm talking to the
castle and uh and i have them pinching
off the cough and um
you know and you guys are singing in the
pub and all that bad time well then
maybe she was laughing a [ __ ] load
during that episode
okay so
but maybe we need to bounce our scripts
off her before we shoot them right and
if they make her laugh then that's a
good she's a good barometer like if we
can get through to jill ah she's well
can we get through to caitlyn
right
i don't know she watches him and laughs
but it's like she's half paying
attention some people though just don't
they can't sit and watch a thing it's
not like for good or bad it's just not
their thing they don't want to sit down
and watch something like i understand
that i'm getting to that point yeah like
i can sit and watch a full
i can watch like a football game which i
recognize is is ridiculous i understand
i certainly don't know you're not you're
not sitting there watching the
commercials like that you get like
little brain breaks right so you get
like a two minutes of action and then
you can go beyond your phone or do
whatever and then you're back
attention if i'm watching what americans
call soccer i can there are no
commercials so i'm working is that what
you were talking about when you said
football
well no i was actually talking about
american football there because i'm not
thank god i got worried don't do that by
the way well i have to do it too for the
record
it used to be called soccer yeah
i know i know but they get angry glenn i
don't know why they get so angry they're
the one who invented that i got a damn
sport and called it soccer i understand
okay all right
[Laughter]
nevertheless i recognize how ridiculous
the ridiculous is to watch any of that
but i can sit there and watch it i'm
having a tough time sitting through
like sitting down to watch a two-hour
movie these days
and it's not because my attention maybe
it's because my attention span but it's
also because i got other [ __ ] going on i
don't know it could be the movies too
and the movies just aren't grabbing you
could be i think everybody's attention
span these days is much shorter than it
used to be because of our phones and
social media
like to pay attention for 22 minutes
it's like whoo it's a lot to ask yeah
let's see what do you got
i saw today that um
that we on somebody sent this to me from
um they sent it to me and ryan actually
because on hulu trending searches the
number one trending search was sunny on
hulu what on all of hulu and the second
one was deadpool
and the third one was deadpool 2 which i
thought was interesting so that we have
a similar audience and then i thought
we're not getting paid enough right
because ryan's very rich yes but it's
all like gin money isn't it like yes i
think he makes a lot of money for those
movies though i think he probably yeah
no oh no we've been vastly underpaid we
know that we've been talking about that
for years we're very pop look
the more people that go and watch the
show maybe they're watching maybe
they're re-watching it with us as we go
i don't know
some people are they are
i had somebody come up to me the other
day and told me that they were that they
just it was actually a friend of mine
and uh
you know not
not somebody who's watching it for any
other reason and they just decided to
watch it again and uh
who was it oh oh it was taran kill him i
was talking to taryn kill him and taryn
was like i started watching the show
again and then you guys started the
podcast and he's like it's timing up
perfectly with me re-watching the show
yeah taryn's great guy you guys know
taran of course i know taren very funny
very funny very talented man lovely guy
[Music]
we got 10 more minutes uh come on guys
oftentimes the last 10 minutes we get
fired up and you know we get let me get
a little more coffee go get some coffee
go get some coffee stretch i'll get a
little more coffee
okay this is right over there take me
over the top yeah
can you tell me what's in that coffee is
it just coffee is it what kind of
special is there like an egg cracked in
there do you have hot pepper is it
brewed in
why why do you ask that because i don't
know
pepper and an egg i don't know
is that is that a crazy thing to ask now
hold on a second no there was nothing
that also had egg in it no
what coffee and eggs hold on a second
what was the thing what was that coffee
what was the bullet coffee that's butter
it's like a
grandfather uh bullet coffee uh which is
otherwise known as an actually known as
bulletproof coffee
uh is uh
is coffee and butter and mct oil uh and
sometimes coconut oil there's different
ways to make it but the main thing that
bulletproof coffee is by the way that's
not pepper okay that might sound strange
but like by the way i never really i did
the bulletproof coffee thing for like
five seconds just absolutely right
destroyed my stomach yes i'm not i hate
it
the reason i was asking was because it's
not that crazy to assume that to go from
butter to an egg i don't know no you
know what i i have uh coffee with my
eggs all the time and i've never thought
to like stir the eggs straight into the
coffee
i could be missing out i mean that's a
very common house get some eggs have a
cup of coffee that's that's i'm down to
try it i'm down to try to like you know
coffee or coffee egg oh i bet how how
about this how about this like you just
take coffee some cold coffee right cold
brew coffee put it in a blender with
some ice
um a couple of crack a couple eggs in
there maybe put some butter in there
right
and a little bit of honey maybe to sweet
well no you can't do that no that's
break that's kind of no actually my
drinks could be my meal i like a meal i
like a drink but i don't want my drink
to be my meal i would drink every single
meal if i could
everything you don't really want to be
chewing and
chewing is a
massive waste of time and energy
that's it that's it well the way you
chew it is a waste of time though
i do chew on it
there's a lot of chewing there's
compartmentalizing of the food
i hate the way it
it sits there for a while or something
else is chewed and moved up into the top
of your mouth then at some point
factory
assembly line is definitely fine
it's something you're
separating the egg from the salt in your
mouth somehow
because you've learned what will
metabolize faster so right now you are
turning food into a liquid
like you but what's so great about you
i love it about you is that you read
somewhere you know years ago that if you
chew your food a thousand times per bite
that it actually was better for your
body
i've been doing that since i was a kid i
swear to god i was always amongst my
friends god i'm crying
my friends when we were kids would would
wolf down their food like we'd go to
mcdonald's and they'd eat their
hamburger in like two bites
and i'd be sitting there chewing forever
and they were like let's go man we got
like we got to ride our bikes across the
train tracks again or whatever the hell
it was we were doing back in the day
and i just couldn't i just chew i just
chew and chew for a man who has to do
like that i you of course you want your
food liquefied right yeah because you
want to be on you want to be on your
bike too yeah it's important to be on
your bike you want to be on the bike
it's the chewing gum an adventure with
your friends going to find dead bodies
look we get it so you understand you
want to be in standby the egg coffee
would be good for you a coffee egg would
be a coffee that's been hard-boiled an
egg that's been hard-boiled in a pot of
coffee that would be good that would be
a god that would be a coffee egg but i
would chop a coffee
like in a percolator right where you're
actually boiling let's make both of
those and then see which ones there's
that's something that a tea is a thing
but wait wait wait wait no it's getting
tea but the the coffee's not going to
penetrate the shell of the egg and
actually affect the flavor so yes it is
how is it going to penetrate the shell
of the egg by the way i love your
passion for this i really do i have no
idea
there really is i have no idea
because i i've had a tea egg before i've
had a tea egg which was an egg that was
kidding boiled in tea and it was
delicious it tasted like tea yeah
very good i hear blowing my mind i've
never heard of that a tea egg yes yes
what is this it's uh it's it's from
other cultures
what culture japan
oh
and chinese chinese chinese okay i don't
really i don't know chinese tea eggs
yes chinese tea eggs and then mine do
they
will you find it in a savory liquid
do they peel the egg before they boil it
that's what we need to know you can't
peel it
before you
boil an egg before you go
do they do they boil it and then like
soak it in the tea or something like
after all right crack it open crack open
the boiled egg and soak it absolutely
should have charlie kelly trying to peel
and unboil
next yeah he can't figure it out he's
frustrated yeah yeah he wants to make
yeah
okay all right coffee egg
i'm gonna go out on a limb here and say
that that's gonna be gross
yeah i'm with you i think that's gonna
be unpleasant um
i i i i so i was what i was gonna say is
um i had that same you and i had the
same gum surgery where you know you're
having like recession and your gums and
you get like a thing and they have to
take like a little bit of tissue from
the roof of your mouth this is generally
how it's done by the way i've heard
recently somebody told me they can do it
with cadavers now that's creepy
but you can get them all done at once
because they're not scraping it from the
roof
you could you can scrape
yeah i i i ca we can already just say
that we should cut this um
they can take the skin the the roof skin
i think of a cadaver
and use that to uh
sticks your gums
no yeah it's creepy it's creepy anyway
thank you so they took it from the roof
of my mouth and then they you know they
do it there and it eventually turns into
your gum tissue and you know heals and
looks normal
um but you can't eat solid food for two
weeks and in that two weeks
my my
my whole thing was i got this i ate the
same foods that i would normally eat
like if i was having
chicken and vegetables and rice
i wouldn't be like well i can't eat that
because that's solid i would just
literally take that put it in a vitamix
add water and blend it into a smoothie
and i would eat chicken rice and
vegetables as a smoothie
and it was great
it tasted you know what it tasted like
chicken soup
yeah you know what i mean
like i would describe this to people and
they'd be like that's disgusting that's
horrible and i'd be like no it's just
it's just soup you're like eventually
it's gonna get blended up before you
swallow it certainly i'm just
i'm just
alleviating my mouth from having to do
the blending work i would heat it up
first so i would heat it up i would cook
it and then sorry to be clear and then
put it in the vitamix and add water
about it was in the uh all raw diet
oh mark yeah i was eating
meats like raw chickens and
i don't know that they i know that they
tried raw chicken um but i don't think
that was ever like a staple of their
diet and they didn't stick with it like
i don't think anyone really that's a
tough thing to stick with no and by the
way i went to the place where we would
get those because there's certain raw
foods you can't that are like against
the law in california you can't
you're not supposed to be able to get
them meanwhile they were scraping
cadavers mouths for yeah gum surgery but
i i this this company that would it was
called
raw and they would they would get i mean
this is so shady they would literally go
to amish farms in pennsylvania and drive
it in this like big white van the kind
of van that you see and you go i gotta
stay away from that van and then they
would park it in a parking lot and you
would buy stuff out of the back of this
van like
you know raw eggs raw butter raw goat
milk
cow's milk raw meat raw
what were the straight out of the salmon
salmonella mobile just like yeah yeah
yeah i think that was what they called
it actually
yeah the salmonella mobile um but uh
they sold salmonella wafers
ugh cut that
um
[Music]
i couldn't help myself that's such a dad
joke that was such a dad joke oh i hate
myself for saying that
um let it go man let it go okay i'm
gonna let it go anyway where was my
point i don't know anyway
so yeah we used to get all these like
raw foods and um and uh like i tr i
tried it to some degree for a while i
was like you know
but i couldn't stick with it it's pretty
there the one thing i tried to eat raw
fish um and i bought like some sushi
grade fish and i cut it up and there was
a [ __ ] worm in there and i was like
i'm done
i'm done right a worm a wiggling worm a
live wiggling worm not a worm it's like
dead
yeah no no no a wiggling worm and i was
like well i'll never right because human
beings started saying you know what
we'll start cooking our [ __ ] because
let's see why do we have to cook food
why are we the only animal that has to
cook its food
well i'll tell you what happened as we
started cooking food
uh our lower intestines our intestinal
tract got smaller which made room for
our brains to get bigger and suddenly we
were not being
yeah that's how it happened so once like
your brain couldn't get big until your
intestines got small how was the
correlation there well just your
intestine was doing a lot more work
because you were just only eating raw
foods and trying to just like the
animals all the other animals okay so
more power was able to but then we got
fire and then as we got fired we got
smarter and our brains got bigger and
then suddenly you know
we're in charge and not that not the uh
you know
the town tiger i don't know
[Laughter]
because we figured out how to trap it
you know in a minute yeah i don't know
enough about brains to dispute it
[Applause]